uh our
theoretically speaking seminar and to
the talk
by Ellie Benson uh on scaling
blockchains with Starks scalable
transparent arguments of knowledge so
just a few words about uh diamonds
Institute so I'm Shafi Goldwater I'm the
director here
and uh
we are a leading uh they're leading
international venue for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
we were established in 2012 with a grant
from the Simons Foundation which has
been very generous to support us for the
last 10 years and now for new 10 years
and we bring together really the world's
leading researchers in computer science
with emphasis on theoretical computer
science and related field as well as the
next generation of
outstanding young scholars fellows and
we explore the use of algorithms and
models and laws of computation in
science engineering and Society at large
in today's lecture
uh is especially
um a proof for the fact that uh
um algorithms and complexity in um from
completely theoretical computer science
make a difference in the real world and
our speaker is Ellie and Ellie is a
co-founder and president of starkware
it's chairman of its board and director
of directors he's been researching
probabilistically checkable proofs from
a complexity and a cryptographic
perspective since you received this PhD
in TCS with Avia victorson where he
studied actually logic and proof
complexity so the word proof is in both
but I think they're very different type
of of Investigations and at least
co-inventor of the Stark fry zero cash
protocols the co-founder of zcash
company and he's been postdoc and health
positions at Harvard MIT Institute for
advanced study the technion and now he
is in star core so uh please join me in
welcoming Ellie
[Applause]
it's a special honor to be here at the
Simons Foundation which is indeed the
leading place the Simons institutes are
the leading place for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
I had the pleasure of being here a few
times in the past and generally I have a
immense gratitude of course for
everything that is theoretical computer
science a lot of respect for it because
uh well it's been doing amazing stuff
for the world and I want to share with
you one such one such example
um it is unfolding as we speak you know
I think hasn't yet reached its full
potential but is already extremely
exciting
um
so this is supposed to be some image of
uh it's a fusion uh
Fusion of atoms where energy is released
but and
probably a lot of you saw the movie
about Oppenheimer
and as mathematicians you're also aware
of the greater context and the amazing
story in which very Arcane fields of of
mathematics so I'm not a physicist so
probably most of them I don't even know
but I know of for instance complex
numbers that were like these you know
imaginary things that had no utility and
all of a sudden turns out that that you
know the world
is best explained using these these
weird objects and probably there are a
few other
Concepts that then made an appearance
and uh
quantum mechanics that I can't even
recount or explain so
um this sort of story where things that
come out of
you know deep math have an immense
impact on the world we all know it from
from physics
um and I want to tell you another such
story that is right now unfolding so
we're in the early days and here the the
math actually comes from from these
places you know from the people that are
here and you know the academic
predecessors and
it's also a story of fusion where on the
one side there's theoretical computer
science in particular interactive and
zero knowledge proofs and also
techniques algebraic techniques of pcps
and from the other side there are
blockchains that are newer but also
these magnificent
it's magnificent and weird technology
and a very colorful one
and uh when you combine the two you get
a massive boost in scale which is
extremely important for blockchains and
I hope to convince you also that
blockchains are very interesting for
Society at large can have a great impact
on us all hopefully in a positive way
and also for privacy
um in blockchain so that's the story
it's the story of an amazing
contribution of theoretical computer
science to the world of blockchains that
is so far already resulted in very
massive boost in scale which is a very
needed a problem to solve in the world
of blockchains and I want to just give
you a few examples of what's going on
today from our own technology at
starkware so using this technology that
comes straight from the core of
theoretical computer science
um we've saved over so far over one
billion dollars for customers in in
things called gas fees over ethereum or
in fees traded over a trillion dollars
for our customers and you know minted a
lot of nfts
um for those of you who know
and we have using this technology that
again all of it
relies on on theoretical computer
science algebraic coding Theory
interactive proofs and photography we
are already scaling the amount of
computation that blockchains in
particular ethereum can do right now
already by a factor of 10x but it's not
going to stop there it can go a lot more
and this is already things this is
something that just happened like two
days ago we reached a rate so ethereum
can process around 10 transactions per
second Bitcoin is the same so on our
system we already witnessed more than
um and it's the first uh you know such
blockchain scaling technology of this
kind that has reached this and this is
not the end
so the interesting thing is that it all
boils down to dealing with integrity and
there's this really beautiful
um
definition of integrity by the novelist
the author C.S Lewis which is that
integrity means doing the right thing
even when no one is watching and
actually I I hope to convince you that
both
what these Technologies give or the way
we use them is we use them in order to
assert and enforce Integrity to have
everyone know that the right thing was
being done even when you're not watching
and the interesting thing is that also
blockchains offer a new way to deal with
Integrity to know that the right thing
is being done in in the case of
blockchains it's
usually associated with financial
transactions or things of value and it
it is also done by a very novel approach
to Integrity to knowing that the right
thing is done but it's really a story of
two different
technologies that deal with this notion
of Integrity making sure that the right
thing is being done even when you're not
watching and I want to start of course
with the stuff that's related to that
comes from from our world which is a
theoretical computer science
so Shafi already mentioned this but for
something like um I'd say 25 years so I
started my PhD studies in well my
undergrad in 93 and then my PhD around
96 and up till
2018 I was fully a theoretical computer
scientist so that's 22 years I think and
since
2018 I've sort of tapered off and became
more of an entrepreneur
or blockchain person
um
and as I said I have the
all that I I've been doing is taking
these this this math and these tools and
basically making it more practical and
so I have immense gratitude for
this beautiful field and its impact on
the world
so
let me tell you a little bit the story
of uh of starkware and the technology
how it came about of course starts way
way earlier
um so think of Stark has some technology
that delivers integrity and it does so
using math and cryptography where
Integrity again is you know knowing that
the right thing is being done when no
one is watching and
in particular
so to describe what is being done or the
way it is being achieved I want to quote
from one of the very important papers
from the early days so this is the bfls
paper by babai Fort now Levine and
segeity and there's just this beautiful
prophetic quote that I I mean I think a
lot of us use it all the time so they
said in this setup so they were talking
about checking computations in poly
logarithmic time where there's this
amazing thing where I mean we all know
beyond the side ability of the halting
problem so one way to phrase it or one
of its consequences is that if you're
given you know a computation and you
want to know anything about it like
whether it terminated or what was the
output then you really cannot save in
the general case at all on just running
it hoping it terminates and then seeing
what the output was and yet in this
weird setup you can have
exponential savings so to quote um they
said in this setup in this world of
interactive proofs a single reliable PC
this was the early 90s so PCS think of
them as some you know very weak computer
can monitor the operation of a herd of
supercomputers with powerful but
unreliable software and untested
Hardware so they had this mental image
where you have this very weak
computational device but that you trust
it and then it can monitor well the
Integrity the correct execution uh that
the right thing is being done over these
vastly stronger computers and if I jump
to the end of like what we're doing is
we are replacing this reliable PC or the
PC that we trust and rely on is actually
going to be a blockchain which is
something that operates at a very low
Pace but it is very trusted for other
reasons and we'll get to later and we're
using that in order to run this kind of
technology and monitor the operation of
arbitrarily powerful computers that are
then helping scale the operations of
blockchain so this is uh so in this
paper from 1990s it's really already
spells out what it is that we want to do
and
so here's an example of uh of
kind of things that that these this
technology proves or asserts Integrity
over so someone is claiming that they
started
system was at a certain state whose hash
was X or like a fingerprint you know
some state of the computation is X
and after processing 1 million
transactions think of them you know
maybe this the state is like you know a
bunch of bank accounts and then um after
one million transactions have been
processed and everyone knows what the
program for processing transactions is
it's some well-known program who's let's
say code is available for everyone to
inspect and we assume that it doesn't
have bugs we reached a new state why
um whose hash is why so
this is the kind of computation that
actually Starker and many other teams
are after proving and and you know we
all need to know the Integrity of such
statements you know our banks are
entrusted with us with such things so
what does the technology do and now I'm
gonna just give you uh
some some
statement of the PCP theorem in
in words that that relate to this so it
turns out that the PCP theorem says that
you can take any such statement which is
specified by a quadruple in this case X
the starting State why the ending State
the program P which could be a generic
turing machine any program
and uh something that balanced the
running time like the number of
transactions or number of steps and if
you have this quadruple you can generate
from it
um basically
um a template for a proof which could be
thought of as some like sudoku-like set
of constraints and it's a puzzle that
needs to be filled by the party making
that claim and claiming that this is
indeed the result of the computation
and the way this works is that the
prover now submits a solution which is
like this fills in some numbers in this
Sudoku like puzzle and then the verifier
causes some random coins picks one of
many many constraints you know that go
along all kinds of directions
queries the entries of that particular
constraint checks whether it satisfies
the Sudoku like challenge so it's not
really Sudoku it's some other set of
constraints
um
and then decides whether to accept or
reject based on this one sample
so the amazing thing
is captured by these three conditions
one is
um succinctness which says that in order
for this verifier to sample a constraint
and to know what is the predicate that
needs to be checked the verifier does
not need to run something that
corresponds to a million steps just
based on the program
and the input and the output and
logarithm of the running time you can
already run a computation that will say
okay here's what I expect to see this is
what will satisfy me and won't satisfy
me and this is succinctness
the second amazing thing is completeness
which is that if indeed the statement is
correct and someone has done this
processing then there's an efficient way
to generate a correct feeling of the
puzzle that satisfies all constraints
and the deepest and hardest to prove
part is soundness which says that if the
statement is incorrect then no matter
which way you fill in these uh missing
numbers
at most one percent of the constraints
will be satisfied which then means that
if you want you know a smaller chance of
error you just need to sample a few more
times and you'll get it
um so this is some version of the PCP
theorem and I assume many of you
recognize
and um
really what
a stark is it's a version of what's
called an interactive Oracle proof that
works almost like a PCP but has several
rounds so the way it differs is that
after the prover has submitted the
solution to the first puzzle now the
verifier samples more Randomness and
generates a second puzzle and the prover
is asked to fill it and then this goes
on a bunch of times and at the very end
uh
the verifier comes and samples these
sort of three-dimensional like
constraints that go across several of
them
so it's very much like you could think
of a PCP as a one round IOP or it's some
generalization of this this model
and then
I can summarize what I did in hindsight
I mean I didn't think of it in those
terms as uh so these constructions are
initial constructions are what we like
to call or Richard Lipton called right
Galactic algorithm so these are
algorithms that work very well
asymptotically but for any input size
that it's let's say smaller than the
number of atoms in the solar system it
is not efficient and it's not worth your
while you'll gain no savings and indeed
I once heard from ikibano that he took
actually a student and asked him you
know let's find the first input size on
which
um you know using these techniques we
actually save something in terms of the
ability to verify the correctness of a
computation and it was some immensely
huge and impractical number so I can in
hindsight summarize my a lot of my
research as just striking off two
letters from there and making it more
practical and this was done over several
uh papers and and works and uh
certainly when I was doing this work I
was not motivated by any practical
application it was just some example of
uh you know here's a cool problem that
is really interesting so let's try to uh
solve it but in hindsight uh
specific computation what for specific
computation
um no these were like uh you know like
uh this uh Benson Sudan was just short
pcps and then interactive Oracle proofs
and everything it was
like
four specific he was looking at specific
language
yeah well I don't know what which
computation Benoit was looking at but
probably
um well if you go back to the uh let's
say to bfls or the almss or these other
early constructions
nearly any computation even if you want
to just prove that let's say one plus
one equals two it'll probably or sorry
the question that you're interested in
answering is what is the minimal size of
computation where the length for the
time needed to verify the correctness of
the computation using these techniques
is let's say shorter by one step than
the time of just naively just running
the computation and I think
the answer to that using the previous
techniques was well you need some
computation that is
more than the number of atoms in the
solar system and
yeah I think that was the kind of
question that they were asking
um
so
now
I told you one part of the story which
is that if you are in a situation where
you have one reliable PC which you want
you trust it and you want to monitor the
operation of a herd of supercomputers
then you know now we have the technology
but the other part of the story is what
is the situation in which you really
have this one trusted weak computer that
you wanted to monitor a herd of super
computers and
that's where blockchains come in and
they give you Integrity you know knowing
that the right thing is being done by
other means and these means have to do
with Game Theory and networks and I want
to now tell you about blockchains now
I'm sure everyone here knows about
blockchains and heard maybe about like
proof of work and how much electricity
they guzzle and being
computer scientists we get drawn to this
aspect of computer science but
I I think the right way to think of
blockchains is as a technology that
solves a very old problem and a very
important problem and that's what I
wanted to try and convince you next
so
blockchains
are forget about
the protocols and the chain of blocks
and the proof of work and the hashes and
whatnot
here is a different way to describe what
blockchains give you so let's start with
uh
this definition of a social function so
I want to Define social functions as
protocols and databases
whose value
necessitates Broad Social consensus
about their integrity
here's an example of something that
isn't a social function if you have
ibuprofen
it's not a social function you don't
care what everyone thinks about it if
you have a headache you take it it's
going to make you feel better
car it's another example you want to get
from one place to the other will take
you there you don't need
you don't care what other thing other
people think
but money is a social function because
the only reason money has value
well I don't know if the only reason but
for money to retain its value it's all
about Broad Social consensus about the
Integrity now what exactly is the right
thing for money well we we have some
you know some some notion of it like for
instance I can't just
make as much of it as I want unless I'm
the Federal Reserve and I call it
quantitative easing or something but
generally speaking you're not supposed
to be able to create like this infinite
supply of it and it's supposed to be
something that's uh scars and I so there
are all kinds of things about money or
if you now make a digital you know you
want certain things to happen like with
money like if I if I'm paying Shafi so
like my consent is needed and she can't
take it away and these sorts of things
so
that's all part of what the Integrity of
money what is the right thing that needs
to be done and then
um
the only way money can retain its value
if there's is if there is somehow Broad
Social consensus about its Integrity
land Registries and other examples a
database that you know all of its value
it's just some file right but this file
is like really really important only
because there's Broad Social consensus
about its integrity and finally things
like social titles you know Reverend or
doctor or Professor again these are
about there must be
their value is all about Broad Social
consensus about their integrity okay so
human societies have been dealing with
the problem of how to administer and
manage social functions ever since uh
societies existed if you go to you know
biblical or mythological stories they'll
be you know the Elders of the town would
sit in some place and there'll be some
protocol where you go there and do some
ceremony and this is an implementation
of a social function this is the way
that everyone knows that whatever you
know this parcel of land moved from
Alice to Bob
um it's it's an implementation of a
social function Okay so
blockchains I'm actually going to use
blockchains we sometimes think of them
as like this chain of blocks so but but
some of these systems don't really have
chains of blocks so let me use a
different term for them let's think of
it as an Integrity wave we're all
familiar with the World Wide Web it's
this pure marvelous peer-to-peer
protocol that gives us a lot of good
things so an Integrity web is a
different way to implement social
functions or to become infrastructure on
which you can Implement social functions
so what distinguishes an Integrity web
and it is the way it implements social
functions is based on an open
peer-to-peer protocol
um that and here's the mysterious part
that I don't fully understand so the
protocol is open to all like you're all
invited to join this protocol and what
the protocol will do is part of the
protocol is it will distribute value to
The Operators of the system and somehow
tie that value to the Integrity of the
system so I I want to give you an
example and of course Bitcoin ethereum
and starknet are examples of integrity
webs and there are thousands of them out
there right if you go to coin market cap
and look at them any of them have tokens
Associated and these tokens are part of
the story so I'll give an example maybe
you know that there's this thing called
the 51 attack against Bitcoin which
basically means that if uh so so this
does have to do with like hashing and
you know cryptography but it just means
that
um well there's some usage of
electricity in order to uh generate new
blocks in Bitcoin now if um
more than 51 percent of the controllers
of this electricity or this activity
decide to work together they can
basically you know change the history of
Bitcoin and do horrible things and
basically just make it completely well
lose its Integrity because part of this
Integrity is like finality and knowing
that you know Alice paid Bob then now
and then this will remain the same thing
forever and in reality when you look at
like the distribution of hash power and
things like that you can see that there
were times where two or three parties
had vastly more than 50 percent of the
uh of this hash power so they could from
a game theoretic uh perspective you know
pick up the phone say okay let's uh you
know Bitcoin is worth whatever maybe
it's I it could be worth now like a
trillion dollars so they could like pick
the phone and say okay there's a
trillion dollars to short here to make
money off of it's a lot of money let's
do this 51 attack maybe short the system
or I don't know like and and uh it never
happened so if you ask yourself like why
is this that it never happened it so I
don't know uh of like the you know the
proper economic game theoretic analysis
for this but I think it has to do with
this uh uh you know virtuous cycle of
tying like what would happen if they do
this kind of attack well all of their
assets or a lot of their assets are tied
to this Bitcoin so now bitcoin's price
is going to go down to zero and they
invested a lot of money and a lot of
effort into purchasing all of this
electricity or whatnot that that led
them to this place and somehow the value
that they have been distributed or are
being distributed is tied to the
Integrity of the system so if you attack
it and ruin it then all of your value
will be
um
ruined did you want to ask someone yeah
is that there's been no evidence that it
happened or we know for sure that it
never happened you know for sure that
never happened in the sense that because
everything is like extremely public and
people talk about these things called
reorgs and D3 orbs and sometimes they do
happen in other blockchains
um on bitcoin it never happened it would
have been like some thing that everyone
would have been discussing so it didn't
really happen the reords are very you
know short and uh
on the order of things that
statistically should happen and make
sense
um so again I want you to think of
blockchains as this
new solution to a very very old and very
important column which is how do we
manage social functions things that are
extremely important for society and if
you think about social functions and and
their impact on our life on human
society you realize that if blockchains
like succeed in really being the better
infrastructure for managing human
societies then then of course they could
have immense power and transformative
power on our lives
um and and you know the jury is still
out this is a new technology certainly
if you look at blockchains right now
they're not there yet we're not using
them you know to for instance to record
marriages and do all kinds of you know
matchings of doctors to hospitals or
record our you know stock Fox papers and
the number of citations in our
reputation but
um yeah it seems sort of weird like
might might we go down this route one
day day but if you think about it right
now the way we're managing all of these
things then have immense value for us I
mean social value immense uh economic
value right is my paper accepted uh how
many citations does it have uh we're
using it the way we're administering it
is is basically by some very
hierarchical and
um
human-centric way of course things like
money and you know central banks and so
on and
um
it wasn't always the case at least let's
say with money right for many many
Millennia money was much more of a
decentralized peer-to-peer thing you
know precious metals and whatnot and not
like uh and decided from from the top so
there's like immense potential here and
it's something that relates to very old
and very important problems so it's not
just uh a bunch of uh whatever nfts and
like weird uh cats or whatnot then
people go and speculate on there's that
as well but there's also immense
potential
so
now it's very important for this for
blockchains to have this very broad set
of operators that's open inviting to
everyone
and because of that you know if you want
people in you know Africa India South
America to be able to participate in
this broad uh network uh and be the
basis of Integrity then now you have
this conflict between broadness and or
what's called decentralization and scale
because suppose you take one of these
systems right now and you want a 10x
it's throughput so how are you going to
do it you're going to say okay go buy a
bigger computer you know more RAM space
uh get a faster internet connection and
then okay so maybe people in Berkeley
and San Francisco a few of them are
certainly if you're a Visa or JPMorgan
you'll go and get this computer but if
you're in South America and Argentina
you won't do this and blockchains have
decided or these Integrity waves always
choose and I think they correctly choose
they choose broadness over scale because
they understand if you lose the scale
then very quickly it will sort of
devolve into a single operator you can
call it whatever Federal bank or a Visa
or something like that and then really
you you're just back to the old system
of trusting some big party and
whether blockchain's managed to succeed
or not we don't know yet but the
ideology and they
is really that you need to have this
broadness if you don't have this
broadness then you lose everything and I
just want to mention that thinking about
this this way you could also have like a
national Integrity webs like you could
have a world where let's say the United
States you know based on your social
security number your you get some you
know digital token some cryptographic
token that lets you participate in some
Integrity web that deals with the US
dollar and uh I think we'll see such
things and then you could have like
systems that are based on uh you know
citizens and democracy for managing a
lot of stuff we don't have it yet right
now I mean there's some
there's some projects that try to solve
this thing called the problem of you
know proof of humanity so World coin is
one such example uh
um but but like we could have many many
different forms of Integrity webs that
sort of bring in democracy transparency
in these things so anyways
um blockchains face this tension between
broadness and scale
and this is exactly where you have this
so going back to this
bfls quote you know where is that single
reliable PC where you really really
trust but you wanted to monitor the
operation of the herd of supercomputers
and the answer is that PC is really an
Integrity web it's a blockchain because
those are very slow and weak
computational devices but extremely
trustworthy and they carry immense value
so why not use them as uh you know the
thing that will run the verifying
technology and check that everything
else is being done correctly
so yeah
um because that's not really clear to me
okay scale scale means how many think of
it like as this on computer actually
ethereum for instance really you can
think of it as computer and look at its
clock break like how many steps can you
do per second you know and you'll get to
some number that's very small uh let's
suppose I don't know what exactly it is
let's say that it's um
10 kilohertz as you know as you measure
a CPU so scale means uh well I wanted to
be uh like one gigahertz as opposed to
10 kilohertz I wanted to be able to
process much more and then another way
to think about it is like these
transactions per second so pick some
very important transaction like Alice
baseball the theory some ether points
this is a very common uh basic
operations right now if the only thing
the Bitcoin does or ethereum is and
Bitcoin actually only allows you those
things there's a certain rate it's like
10 transactions per second roughly so
you're saying oh I want the 100
transactions per second you know Visa
processes
thousands of transactions per second and
that Peaks more and WeChat pay and
alipay are probably at a million
transactions per second so scale means
you want a 10x and just like we do with
all the things that we care about okay
what is broadness broadness is how
distributed among and how open is the
set of operators of this network right
what is the base of trust who who has
the power and who's controlling it so
blockchains right now again I said you
know maybe one day the US will offer
every citizen with a social security
number a digital token and now you'll
have networks based on this right now
it's solved by
um you know things like proof of work
you bring electricity and hashing or by
proof of stake which means somehow you
have already a few tokens in that uh in
that Network and then you know based on
that that's the way that you can operate
the system but but importantly everyone
is invited to the table and you want it
to be the case that everyone can join in
and bring in their laptop and track
what's going on and view view it so
that's broadness now of course they
contradict each other because if you're
going to increase the scale then this
laptop can participate and maybe I don't
have the means to get uh not a big
computer
so
um now just sharing my personal story
um this realization though I didn't
phrase it in these terms none of this
um so for me the red pilling moment was
in 2013 I was giving talks about you
know implementing pcps in practice and I
gave them mostly an academic places like
not well not at Simon's but like these
places and
uh people didn't understand what I was
doing and I couldn't convince like I
couldn't find good examples for like why
would uh for instance a bank want to use
a proof system and I still don't have
good examples and the reason like if you
think about this where do you have a
situation where a single reliable PC
really really wants you know is willing
to pay money or in order to uh to verify
some computations done by a
supercomputer so you would say oh of
course I want to verify what's going on
with my bank no but actually
you don't need that you're not you the
bank is not willing to give you that and
the bank doesn't need to give you that
you're in a trust it based on other
reasons and and you're not going to get
it so if you go like example after
example I to this day don't yet know of
a very good example outside of
blockchains where you want to deploy
proving technology not not theoretically
but like practice you know which
business cases
you have people and institutions saying
we will pay money for having this
technology and we are also willing to
suffer the degradation in let's say
compute time the results from them
because generating and verifying proofs
is not as
efficient as just running a computer
now
what happened to me was that I chanced
upon a conference
in San Jose it was the Bitcoin
conference back then there was pretty
much only Bitcoin and they gave the same
talk there and I when I got off of the
podium instead of people like being Grog
AI then like oh very interesting you
know talking like in the sense of you
know not interesting like why are you
doing this and you know some people came
to me in later years and said everyone
was behind your back saying like why is
he doing this craziness of like trying
to implement and code these things and I
didn't have very good answers so going
down
um from the podium at this Bitcoin
conference so a lot of the core
developers came and didn't ask what are
you going to do with it so on they said
okay where's the code and now here are
three problems that we want to do with
it like we need to solve with it
tomorrow
and I said to them no you're just you're
being polite you don't really want to
solve these problems I said no no these
are like burning problems that that we
need to solve and we're going to use it
tomorrow and it just took me by surprise
so I felt something
I didn't I couldn't articulate what it
was that I felt but I felt that there's
something like very very interesting
here and that was the point where in
hindsight that was the watershed moment
or the red pilling if you saw the Matrix
movie
um moment for me it was I just this very
decisive moment uh uh where I felt that
there's some calling here that I
couldn't quite
put my finger on like why is it
um anyway so
now what happened was that my co-authors
and and me so we were anyways
implementing such systems in code and uh
we published this paper called zero cash
that actually used the Privacy angle so
zero knowledge proofs invented by Shafi
and Silvio and Charlie rakoff in 85.
um
to
Shield the payer the payee and the
amount being uh
paid
and we published this in academic paper
and then
um I was one of the founding scientists
along with all the six other co-authors
of this paper of zcash that was the
first use case of a practical let's call
it product or system that actually uses
general purpose meaning General
computation uh amenable
ZK technology or ZK snarks based on
elliptic curves
um for for something and this was the
zcash cryptocurrency that still exists
um I was then still working on the more
PCP related uh technology or PCP
inspired this led to fry and Stark I'll
say a few more words about them later
and in 2018 we published the papers and
then we found it starkware and it's the
first case of uh
first use case of using these systems
for scalability so when we came out with
starkware
um we were uh saying you know there's no
way blockchains are gonna conquer the
world without there being an immense
scaling problem and we have the right
technology for it and then what happened
was that a lot of people like didn't uh
didn't believe this they said first of
all there's no scaling problem we don't
see it right now and we don't believe
that this technology can can solve the
problem but you know we still went at it
and luckily there were enough investors
and VCS that believed in this and were
willing to fund it and actually a lot of
that was based on the success of Z cash
so the
demonstration of uh these this set of
technologies that came from theoretical
computer science
um convinced people that this is a
worthy uh worthy thing
and now I don't know if you're following
the blockchain space and so on well now
everything in computer science is like
AI this and AI that so no one cares
about anything else but still
um like ZK proofs as a means to uh scale
blockchains is a very very hot topic uh
within blockchains everyone recognizes
that's the right way
um to solve a problem and like go to the
next level uh luckily for us Starker was
basically the first to say this
um we have now over 120 employees and
expanding and a bunch of products I'll
say a few things about that but I want
to put this technology in like uh more
context so going back to the you know to
the uh uh basically the pedigree where
this comes from so I think it all starts
with gmr like many good things like gold
versus
the discovery or invention of
interactive proofs and zero knowledge
proofs as a complexity class
um as it started as a complexity object
and a cryptography of the object
um you know what can this kind of thing
do
and then so of course there's I'm not
going to survey all of the literature I
just want to highlight some things
um so the sound check protocol uh
and and that paper first of all has this
amazing
Revelation which is that
algebra and low degree polynomials and
arithmetization are really a good way to
you know they're really a good tool to
bring to the table if you're dealing
with interactive poops
everything today in these uh protocols
uses arithmetization and I'll say a few
words about that and it's completely
surprising well both the subject
protocol and uh what came out of it but
like
you want to deal with uh interactive
proofs and you know prove certain
statements about computation why on
Earth should the polynomials over low
degree uh be relevant it's completely
non-trivial and mysterious uh and by now
we know that you can you know take them
away and replace them with some things
but they're still the most efficient way
to solve the problem practically
speaking and it's very surprising
I already mentioned this poly log
verification paper that that mentioned
oh here's some use case that you could
use this technology for like a practical
one they actually said you could verify
these big computations in much smaller
time
um and of course the PCP theorem that
took this to the Very extreme case where
there's just one long message that you
can query only three bits of and uh and
just look at that and an interesting
thing is that the PCP ethereum for many
many years well maybe till this day
because it's such a marvelous theorem in
has all these amazing implications to
hardness of approximation
most of the research well at least well
I'm not following the research today but
like when I was following the research
most of the research was about the
implications in a proximability and the
positive applications to
polygologarismic verification were the
pathless traveled by uh and in hindsight
it was very very fortunate that when I
came to my postdocumented Sudan
suggested the question that led down
that path of oh you know let's look at
the proof length and make it shorter why
because it's a cool question so that's
how I actually started my path that lid
all the way to this
um
well there you go I mean wasn't it what
in the fine grained and like uh okay
uh
that wasn't okay
I should have known it back then you
know we should have
um
now uh the next batch of papers that I
want to mention
um sort of now look at these protocols
with the very concrete complexity kind
of uh angle and say okay suppose we want
to do practical stuff with them so can
we make things a little bit better again
some of this is in hindsight I can say
that the quasi-linear pcps as I said uh
when we thought about it was we didn't
think about practical applications but
it was about making things a bit more
efficient in practice of course there's
the proofs for Muggles paper that takes
the subject protocol and shows how to
make it practical
um there were because pcps were viewed
as as too complicated for uh concretely
inefficient there was this very nice
realization that you can have these
linear pcps and use additive homomorphic
encryption
um to solve the problem and also
separately and not for these reasons
pairing-based cryptography uh you know
was discovered by Bonet funky and Zhu
um and then became really instrumental
and now if we look at it so this like
sort of uh Red Line is now let's look at
the implementations or like much closer
to implementations so there's the fry
protocol that I want to tell you about
there's things called inner product
arguments
um that I'm not going to mention too
much in their quadratic span programs
that use elliptic curve pairings and
this is already all of these things are
now being used in practice
an interesting thing is that even though
the gkr and subject Protocols are
extremely efficient and uh in fact
actually don't need any cryptography in
certain settings
um they till now they aren't yet used in
blockchain but I think this is also
going to change and the common names for
some of these things you see out there
are called Starks and snarks
um and I just want to say that there's
like well this is the important line
there are dozens of projects and
hundreds of developers that are working
they call themselves ZK researchers and
they are building the code and systems
and are getting funded by VCS and trying
to use it mostly for scalability but
also for privacy if you heard about the
tornado cash Affair there were just some
people arrested uh for uh actually using
writing code
um you know basically a
re-implementation of the zcash protocol
over ethereum that the Department of
Justice claims was
not only used by uh the North Korean
Lazarus group but also be knowns to some
of these developers so some of them are
in custody and being investigated so
it's a
I mean I mentioned you know quantum
mechanics and of course all know that
there's you know you can use this
technology for all kinds of things and
uh
I'm not aware of any technology they
can't use for can't be used both for
good things and for bad things and uh
um there's that
so a little bit more about what Starker
has been up to yeah just uh so uh the
first thing we did was just build a
settlement engine that just helps uh
projects that deal with cryptocurrencies
save money by using this technology so
it's all about like taking the
technology of a verification that is
exponentially faster than running a
computation and using that as the way to
get integrity and I mentioned already
that we that's been very
successful and beneficial for our
customers the next thing that we did is
that we basically wanted to make this
technology accessible in its first
Incarnation was extremely inaccessible
if you wanted to
you know you had some system that you
wanted to scale you would have to work
with polynomial constraints and write
them by hand do a lot of complicated
stuff so then we came up with a better
way which is to offer a programming
language that is very efficient when it
comes to proof generation but also is
fully during complete and actually is a
pretty good programming language and now
there are probably hundreds of full-time
developers writing
um writing code in this language and
and then
we also
have launched a
general purpose sort of Integrity web
called starknet that uses it and it's
you know thriving so I just want to
explain what this what starting it is
this uh
so we mentioned this broad this
broadness and scale tension and
blockchains right now they don't use
proofs as part of the way they they deal
with scaling so
what starknet is it's an Integrity web
layer too so what does Layer Two mean it
means that you use the basic blockchain
in this case it's ethereum which can
ethereum can think of it as some slow
it's your trusted PC it runs at a very
slow pace and it's very costly each
operation of it but it's extremely
trusted because it has very good
broadness
um so we use that as the layer one and
we run a verifier on this PC and then it
monitors the operation of this herd of
Superbook supercomputers in this case
these are the provers and sequencers of
this layer two that can deal with much
greater scale and so starknet is an
Integrity web on ethereum that resolves
the broadness
and scale tension using math in
particular start validity proofs and the
way it goes is that it invites
arbitrarily powerful computation and
operators even ones where you don't
necessarily want to assume trust over
you can now assert Integrity over them
by basically telling them okay whenever
you want to update the state of your
system you have to supply a proof that
the right thing was being done when no
one is watching and now we're going to
verify this proof and we have
cryptographic certainty that that you
didn't you know that you only updated
the system according to this well-known
program that everyone has seen and
checked
and
this is a way to give you much greater
scale just mention that you can also use
recursion so you can now run verifiers
on starknet itself it will verify
something called the layer three and
then you have even more scale and this
can go on and on for a while and
probably will
so
now in the remaining time so how much
more time do I have like uh so usually
about seven minutes
very good so seven minutes I just want
to say a few words about I mean
being theoretical computer scientists
like I have to tell you a little bit
about the algebra luckily I mean I have
a whole bunch of slides including some
math stuff but uh we won't get to that
so uh
so I just want to tell you about
arithmetization and just how magical and
uh strange it is
um so what is arithmetization
arithmetization is this reduction
from questions about computational
integrity right has
this program executed correctly to
problems about relations between a bunch
of polynomials so you start with
something like this computation you know
have I Pro is it the case that I have
processed correctly a million
transactions so there's no polynomials
there's no algebra here and then you
move to a new statement that looks
something like this
um you want to convince me that you've
done the right thing okay well
I come up with these two polynomials you
know q and R and some degree bound you
want to convince me that the right thing
was being done you want me to accept
this new state well please provide four
polynomials a b c and d such that the
weird relation between q and R holds you
know and this is just some example of a
relation
a relation between polynomials you know
does this equality hold so again just
take a step back and see how weird this
is you started with a question about
computation and now you have this
question about polynomials and the
relation between them it's very strange
um
but the nice thing is that
if you manage to apply this reduction
then you're in a very good situation
because
if it is the case that you can't find
these polynomials a b c and d
right because maybe this claim you're
making is just false
well now we can have a very succinct and
efficient way to check this which is
we're going to sample a random element X
just evaluate the two sides of this
equation and see if they're equal and
the nice thing is that when you're
dealing with low degree polynomials if
the total degree is you know D uh you
can have Atmos D values on which two
distinct polynomials fool you that
they're the same if they're not
so if you sample from a large enough
domain which is what all of these proof
systems do suddenly you get like very
good probability of discovering that
someone has has not been operating with
integrity and
it's
it's very mysterious that this works but
this is arithmetization
and um now you're faced with a new
problem which is
you really the core of the problem now
becomes how do we enforce this uh
Integrity with respect to low degree
polynomials so all we need to do is find
a way to get Bob to commit to these low
degree polynomials the degree D and then
actually when he's asked about X
evaluate them honestly that's really the
new problem so if you can solve this
problem of getting
people to commit to any polynomial of
degree D but but not change their answer
afterwards and evaluate correctly on it
then you solve the problem and these
things are now called polynomial
commitment schemes so it's a way to
commit to a polynomial and then evaluate
it so what is the ideal functionality
suppose you fix a field and a degree
bound D then what you want is this
functionality so Bob who's going to try
and convince us of the correctness of
the statement is going to send a
polynomial to some trusted party let's
call him Tom
and this is going to be any polynomial
of this choice but of degree at most D
and Alice gets to specify the degree
and now LS is going to ask Tom what you
know what is the value of this
polynomial at a random point a and and
Tom is going to answer the correct
answer for that polynomial P that Bob is
deposited with him
so this is the problem that all of these
different protocols and approaches are
ultimately trying to solve
exactly so what you want to do is
simulate this without a trusted party so
how does it look well
um you Bob is going to send there's no
Tom anymore so Bob is going to send some
cryptographic commitment or some
commitment to this polynomial
and then Alice is going to query but
there's no more Tom Right Tom doesn't
exist
um so Alice needs to query Tom for the
value of the polynomial at a point a and
Bob is going to answer with some value B
and then they're going to apply some
protocol that basically is going to help
Alice decide whether this answer was
correct or not and what we want is
completeness meaning that if indeed the
value of the polynomial at Point a
equals B then Alice will be happy
soundness which means that the
probability that Alice is fooled is
smaller than some reasonable number
let's say 2 to the minus 128 you want
scalability which means that you want
like very good proving time and very
good verification time in particular
verification time better be poly
logarithmic uh you want to care about
the security you know which crypto is
something assumptions are you going to
use is it going to be post Quantum
secure you want universality you know
all finite fields and Rings Maybe
so the fry protocol it turns out to be a
very simple protocol and also very
efficient in in practice it's very fast
and it's proving time is something like
six times the degree the verification
time is something like 20 times the
logarithm of the degree those are the
constants under the O notation
um it is post Quantum secure and it
actually even works over all finite
fields we didn't know this at in the
beginning but now we know how to get it
over all finite fields
[Music]
um
and I'm not gonna I think I'll I'll stop
here but uh and answer questions so
there's a bunch of math slides I can
share them but there's also papers and
oh this is not the hour for
subjecting you to things like uh this
right
[Applause]
well now we open the floor to questions
anything
so I
I have trouble smothering
how would an interview that is being
used for uh like a social function
it does not transferable
like I mean like okay for example how
would it look like
I didn't understand
how would an Integrity win yeah how
would an Integrity web that like
distributes academic degree
okay so one thing you can do is you
could tie the value of academic degrees
to the total Integrity of that web so
for instance maybe my reputation
um
so suppose I'm now thinking on the fly
but suppose
my reputation generally is worth let's
say economic value meaning some protocol
from like proving that I today
and not been repeated
and uh and then there can even be some
uh slashing or some economic
punishment if I found to be
irreputable
and uh
so now I could start making statements
and say
one Centurion award and then
um if I
start making false statements then at
least risk my reputation
so you could so reputation systems are
one way to deal with it
another is you you could ask like well
if you think about the day like how does
someone come by
um
an academic degree
for some hierarchical system right you
you get a PhD if there's a committee
it's some accredited institution and so
on so you can follow that chain and say
what if this whole process is actually
done on an Integrity Way
so everyone knows that if you got a PhD
from Berkeley Berkeley is an accredited
institution it means something and then
the fact that uh someone else made up
some institution you know any
institution and gave you a PhD it will
the world will know how to deal with
that
um so you said that you're going to use
you're using L1 right to do the
verification and L2 to basically propose
uh challenges or groups groups right
well
um L2 operates at a much higher speed it
still has like transactions and
everything
um but
and one you know in order to update the
state of this layer two uh you sort of
have a safeguard which is later on Smart
contract that verifies in our case start
proofs so State the system can never be
updated until layer one is verified the
purpose of approval right what what
stops player two from just like sending
a lot of like transactions
like
um
is that a bad thing that's a good thing
right computation and stuff yes that one
has all kinds of well L1 has transaction
fees and also Layer Two have transaction
points and then you pay more for
congestion so like if everyone's there's
a fascinating uh you know area like how
do you correctly price uh
transactions on
various layers
like L2 you still need to like
incentivize the approvers that yeah yeah
so Layer Two uh yeah on start net it's
going to be an Integrity web which means
there will also be value distributed in
the start met token to operators of the
network
um and hopefully their integrability
will be tied to that value
um yes so in the starting system right
now it's still a single entity running
um the sequencer and approver but within
a year hopefully we'll reach
decentralization which means that anyone
can be a sequencer an approver and there
will be both transaction fees and new
maintain of tokens that go towards those
as all Integrity website
first you said something
nobody talks about nothing but this
moment yeah but on the other hand people
are talking about the value of things
and
um
yeah
so oh I should say that a very hot uh
topic today is called the zkml or zkai
and
um so you could say like we all have
this uh tendency of you know there's
some hot thing and everything is you
know I mean but well
they tell or how do you deal with data
how do you price it and so on is is very
very
essential in in blockchain
and
um
yeah I think that well part of the
long-term vision of what Integrity webs
could be is that
each individual will be will be the
true owner of their data which isn't the
case right now right are credit scores
are that like all of this valuable data
that we are generating
it's extremely important you know our
social networks our credit scores uh
when have we defaulted or non-defaulted
on on a loan all of this information
which is worth trillions uh is in it's
our information it's in the hands of
several uh very powerful centralized
institutions and they they make a lot of
money off of it so part of the vision of
these Integrity webs is that it will be
reversed so for instance you will be the
true owner of your credit history and
everything it will actually be under
zero knowledge only you can access it
and then you can also offer licenses for
processing you but you know for instance
you'll get a cut of the fee and an
Integrity web which is transparent that
everyone sees it can enforce this so you
can still have your data everyone will
see it but you could say if you're you
know some license that would say if
you're a credit score uh or if you're in
an AI agent and you want to use this
data well whenever you process and make
some prediction about near about society
and use my data you need to generate the
proof that you paid whoever it is that
you touch their data from the chain so
of course you need immense scale from
that but I think that's the direction if
I look ahead you know 20 years yes this
could be the situation so yes when AI
agents are using our data we would be
compensated or and they will prove that
they let's say compensator used fairly
according to the licenses that we put it
will also be on the Integrity web and I
will say I can say everyone can use my
data or maybe some parts suppose I have
some very rare medical condition that I
am really incentivized that people work
on one of these rare diseases so
probably I'm going to put a license on
that part that says you know just just
use it right everyone who has this
condition we all want together you know
don't pay me anything but maybe my
credit rating or things that I know are
of men's value I will say yeah you can
process this it's it's out there but if
you're processing it and pay me whatever
I sent for each time you're using and
this could be part of the license
the second thing was you said that uh in
2013 you couldn't think of a use
a daily maybe there's this whole issue
of governance
or again an ml system so they don't get
too powerful and uh and how you really
govern a
computations
how much is being computed on you know
what's being done
except we put some sort of proof you
know I don't know if you need a
blockchain for it but you need to do
some Central Authority
which wants to verify that these big
companies are doing what they claim
they're doing
yeah but right like the way I would
solve it today was I would send
an auditor or an accountant just like
you know it's the same situation Banks
what no it's a visual thing you you have
a computer
the
right compute they're not getting to be
too powerful so this is small business
control is a huge yeah like but the way
so no I theoretically I like it but like
practically
um this isn't different from let's say a
bank so a bank also runs some huge
computation it's a well-known entity uh
so what the government the way the
government solves this problem and of
course you know that very bad thing
could happen if no one checks what the
banks are doing so how does the
government solve it it first of all says
you know please Mr CEO of the bank you
know sign off that you've been operating
with Integrity okay once a year one
several every several months they
actually ask you for reports give us a
lot of information we also get to send
people to look at what you're doing to
look into your computers and oh if you
really cheated then you go to jail or
you face something
so you could apply the very same
mechanism to AI you can say you know we
need you to first of all CEO please sign
off that whatever you're adhering to
these uh guidelines and we're going to
send Auditors from time to time we'll
pass a law that you must let those
Auditors uh view your code
and the last question was
um
let's go with Hardware specialized
Hardware I remember years ago
yeah there would be this Hardware yeah
rather than computation
um it's sort of a basic operation yes
verification is the is very efficient
proving they would do well that you
would set your computation up so that it
would be easy to verify in the future
yes
okay so it would be a hardware would do
some extra things
verify in the future there's something
you still be doing first of all
um so there are by now like probably
five or more
startups that already got funded that
are doing uh ZK Hardware so they're
speeding up on fpgas and rocket with A6
but I'm gpus and the fpgas they're
working to speed up
um the operations of smarts and starts
and things like that and
yeah I think that the big question is
there is when will It's like this uh you
know when is the market ready so like uh
what is the right time to start working
on it because for a hardware thing you
want right tens of thousands of people
to need this hardware and use it and the
question is
they want to start working let's say two
years before that now
two years out well we have tens of
thousands of
um
servers that want to run like these very
efficient things I don't know yeah I
think maybe we're still like maybe it's
like four years out so maybe you want to
start your Hardware ZK Hardware I think
let's say in two years time
there are some companies some companies
like four or five that are already
working on
it
so tornado cash is like probably the
best example of uh of these Technologies
kind of rubbing nation state the wrong
way yeah how can I going forward do we
position these Technologies in a way
where they protect kind of privacy for
kind of a global decentralized Community
you know but
you know government currency concerns
and all this stuff aren't necessarily
discarded like how can they co-exist or
are they just naturally going kind of
butt heads and
it's gonna be a game of cat in the mouth
um a bit of the both a bit of both
meaning if you think about the internet
right
um the internet is pretty decentralized
and pretty free announced and open and
it's not heavily monitored or regulated
in most modern democracies
and we all know that that you know
people are using email and
um on the internet for dealing in you
know drugs setting up uh terrorists and
assassination attacks
transmitting the child pornography and a
lot of Very Bad Things
right
um
so there's that
and and we know that these things exist
now
it's a really good question like
what is the right answer even for the
internet right should you monitor
um all transmissions so that for
instance you catch the
uh
terrorism and
drugs and child pornography
will it actually work what are you
losing by doing so
um
I'm more of the opinion that
the
harm of like too much monitoring is way
greater than the benefits
um and I think the same thing will apply
I think to blockchains one interesting
thing is you could bring to bear it's
not a silver bullet but you could bring
to bear the same sort of ZK technology
you know
one way to say it is that whatever
Society decides is the right policy that
must be enforced if you can write it
into an algorithm you could actually say
prove to me in zero knowledge that you
adhere to this algorithm
now the reason it's not a silver bullet
is that most of the stuff that we want
to police and monitor you can't just
write an algorithm that will you know
that you can't go across think about
like you know don't send child
pornography so okay well there are a
million ways to uh overcome that no
algorithm will be able to catch
so
yeah it will be Captain just like all
crime or illegal stuff is cat and mouse
forever and uh it's not going to be
different here
of how how much can you steal
we don't know the balance like they must
exist but they're very very
there's what we can skip like the way
scaling works is that at every given
point in time there's a bottleneck
um
and I can tell you for now for us now it
is actually the sequencer it comes
before the proofs at all it's like this
virtual machine that does the sequencing
and in there there's uh you know some
some things that are the bottleneck
the nice thing is that
um
I don't know of any theoretical
limitation to you know on ethereum
settling
a trillion DPS
uh
as long as like well there's some things
related to data like
if you always change State and you need
to report that to ethereum that's one
hard limit but if let's say just some
computation that runs at uh you know uh
one Tera
hurts uh or a thousand terahertz I don't
know of any theoretical limitation
um
so
it exists but we can probably using
current technology but like okay using
certainly the current theory and more
Hardware you can probably take
all of uh WeChat pay alipay
Visa settle it all on ethereum using
start proofs recursive ones and saying
things like that so what living is the
number of conversions are just
if you don't come do
in terms of verifying a proof there's
almost no limit it now the question is
what do you report to ethereum other
than the proofs in many cases you want
ethereum to also get the state diff
and then like you know what has changed
in your data set between point A and B
it's called a roll up if you do that
then that's one limit
you could also move to something called
validium which is you don't actually
report that and then there's some other
it's called the data availability layer
but then the question is what is the
limit of that data availability layer
so it's not about the computation and
the proofs it's about these other things
where proofs don't help you like how
much data they want to say for instance
if you want all the videos of cool cats
to be uh on your system then the
question is
you know again this broadness this
laptop there's only so many cool cat
videos that it can save so you need some
other solution for dealing with that
um
you mentioned early on that you were
considering potential application being
matching like for example with hospitals
and residents yeah
um
so how would you consider like being
able to manage like the expensive
structure in those cases
um okay people to trust this you know
Integrity web and move to the system
well this is this is already something
that is today so today there's a lot of
matching going on chain for
um
uh Trading and there are several
approaches to it like you could actually
if you have some Metric of how good is
it matching suppose they're like you
know bids and uh
let me see that
cells in my orders then you can Define
some Metric as to how good is the
solution and some of these systems they
say anyone everyone can see the order
book everyone can submit a solution
there's a metric if you can uh you know
the one that gives you the best that
according to that metric get something
and get some of the transactions you
could have something similar uh you know
for matching let's say with hospitals
you know there's a the either the
hospitals or the residents or both of
them maybe put some money because they
care about this and then you can just
have
um
you know various parties compete and
then if you can have a scoring then you
can distribute value to the winner of
this auction
that's one within another way is to have
a smart contract like the code that
actually solves the matching if you have
like an optimal algorithm then you can
just run that
and prove the correct execution of it
verification protocol and it's supposed
to come up with a clever new thing what
happens the past is okay you store the
okay
I guess all the transactions and things
that happened before using this key
immune kind of because if it wasn't
broken and so you could still you can
say okay here's a state that I trust now
I mean actually we constantly do it in
our system you know we when there's a
new version of let's say the verifier
that has more functionality we do some
sort of upgrade in the labs and a new
set of polynomials
in the way we actually the reason we use
it is we keep adding these um we call
them built-ins like uh
these are like sort of like dedicated
circuits for checking certain operations
that are more efficient like you know a
hash function or then you constantly add
more functionality but then with your
protocol with the ethereum have a change
also
you upgrade the smart contract yes you
say my verifier it still runs right now
it still runs the same kind of
Technology but well let's set a
polynomial constraints has been enlarged
and includes something new
of course if there's a bug in the new
version then like with all cases so you
have a problem
and how does the uh
governance on who can update support
like a book in connection
so yeah that's a very it's a huge topic
of how to deal with governments uh there
are like many questions you know game
theoretic legal and uh
what approach is called the Dow approach
which is the token holder sort of uh
submit stuff and improvements on it has
pros and cons so you could have a smart
contract that says in order for this
other contract to be upgraded I need to
see this is 50 have you know voted for
it uh that's one popular approach
another is to have called multi-six we
have trusted
set of uh wise Elders that are hopefully
publicly known and a majority of them as
the sign and uh
so for starknet right now we are in
transition or we're constantly
decentralizing it more so right now
these upgrades are still pretty
centralized but it's part of this
decentralization processes making
changing that something it's a very
interesting question like what is the
right governance for these things
not everybody has
nickel expertise to their to verify that
the new verifiers oh yes
in general governance is
governance is very tricky
auditing code security is very very
tricky there's no way
to actually have code that you know for
sure doesn't have bugs
very
but I think that
what is sort of
gives
you some comfort is that
first of all yeah all software has bugs
complicated enough this has been true
you know
on the side of benefit of the halting
problem
this is true for all systems you know
medical devices
Cars airplanes
um
somehow Human Society usually well
there's some really horrible
catastrophic failures but like
you know people know to deal with this
so it's going to be the same thing like
there's no there's no way to completely
resolve this
thank you very very much
[Applause]